السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هاد
له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له وان محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله عليه
وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما
كثيرا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما
بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله وخير الهدي
هدي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم وشر الامور محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار
‏figes in islamic
world two the
iges can you guess what they
about we are delving into a of
im
signed by the for leaders of arabic
‏could be the highly sign matter that
matches sture of these two
figures
such a lel of
me this meeting and the
conversation that took place
documented and it was something
astonishing astonishing
may because we are used to ‏certain typ
of issues added in such
meetings we are now thinking or i think
you are thinking in a different
direction about the content of this
meeting between these two significant
figures that i consider the most
important the most important figures in
human
history the perspective of crucial
issues differs from ours
‏the place
where the place of
the
place inac people place
ابراهيم
ازر
ناحور ابراهيم ابن ازر ابن
ناحور اد
محمدن عبد اللهن عبد المطلب محمد بن عبد
الله بن عبد المطلب صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏when did they when did they
meet where was the
mee was
the محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم صحيح البخاري هي ابراهيم عليه السلام
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
ابراهيم ابراهيم ج
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلمصلى عليه
وس محمد
[Silence]
سبحان الله والحمد لله ولا اله الا الله
والله اكبر
يا
محمد اق من
السلام
محمد
father con
ميكم
ابراهيم ابراهيم عليه السلام
[Silence]
ابراهيم
الله
passed imag
‏im
fathered find
tole could
sign
father
con and
‏father as as
are
as
asut leading you
tos that
سحان
الله imagine that you gu a friend
relevance and every this friend
relev a
tree par
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم فمن دل على خير
فله اجر فاعل كما صح عن النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم از
[Silence]
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى واصبر نفسك مع الذين يدعون ربهم
بالغ والعشي يريدون
وجهه ولا تعد عيناك عنهم تريد زينه الحياه
الدنيا ولا تطع من اغفلنا قلبه عن ذكرنا
واتبع هواه وكان امره فرط
[Silence]
الله ومن اعرض عن ذكري فان له معيشه ضنكا
ونحشره يوم القيامه
اعمى
res يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا الله ذكرا
كثيرا وسبحوه بكره واصيلا
الله
afternoon these are are the
words
ig what do think two
infu to me
‏tooc as was
important the
greatest in hum
history when they
inen even imaging it
difficult the vales of
‏props are v different
[Silence]
‏perse and behaviors often
not
inew our own
belar
kind how
‏remember the
creerse
orch
ex commed you to remember him to your
heart
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
سبحان
الله والحمد
لله لا اله الا الله والله
اكبر اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
الانبياء والمرسلين سيدي سنا محمد عليه
وعلى اصحابه افضل الصلاه واتم التسليم اما
بعد
given luxurious
fac and he lives in a village where
people
care how that de
‏he will of course make sure it's clean
tidy whenever it gets dirty he washes it
cleans it and puts in
effort to make sure it is clean in order
to maintain his
standing among
people and that's pretty
intuitive but you that man
‏what if you are that
man and that of was your
heart and the one looking at
you the looking at
it الله سبحانه
وتالى your
creat while that
dirt is your
bads your sins
اتق الله حيث ما كنت واتبع السيئه الحسنه
تمحها وخالق الناس بخلق
حسن في الله
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله
are
first areed
[Silence]
استغفار ادفع بالتي هي احسن نحن اعلم بما
يصفون واقم الصلاه ترفي النهار وزلفا من
اللي ان الحسنات يذهبن
السيئات ذلك ذكرى
للذاكرين الله سبحانه
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى والذين اذا فعلوا فاحشه او ظلموا
انفسهم ذكروا الله فاستغفروا
لذنوبهم ومن يغفر الذنوب الا الله ولم
يصروا على ما فعلوا وهم
يعلمون
الله and do
not those
‏make
mistakes we
give us
ase ما الله
‏how can you dis and
worship you
hr
don't
on you more incre
dev we worship moree
dev because
[Silence]
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم تعرض الفتن على الحصير عودا عودا
فاي قلب
اشربها نكتت فيه نكته
سوداء واي قلب انكرها نكتت فيه نكته بيضاء
حتى يصير القلب ابيض مثل
الصفا لا تضره فتنه ما دامت السماوات
والارض والاخر
اسود مربدا كالكوز مجخيا لا يعرف
معروفا ولا ينر ولا ينكر
منكرا الا ما اشرب من
هواه صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم ‏straw by
straw whichever heart took
it a black dot was added to it and any
heart that denies
it a white dt ised to it until it is two
hearts on white as marble no
temptations two no temptations ‏will har
him as as the and
earth the other is as intense
black ups upside down
ci enes
himi enes
good bades
except was
out of
‏from his
mind tring a
c thats
down
is that
sin
one in
the
asing either you ac on ‏bl white or
slate that will drag what is
after or remove it and avoid its
har a heart that inves
filth bounce back when
another
to it isn out and compl dred
‏dring owner into the
swamp the day of
judgment الله سبحانه
وتالى
sick
dark يوم لا ينفع مال ولا
بنون الا
الله بقلب
سلم
الله اعلموا ان الله سبحانه وتعالى امركم
بامر فبدا به بنفسه فقال جل من قائل ان
الله وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها
الذين امنوا صلوا عليه وسلم تسليما اللهم
صل وسلم على عبدك ورسولك محمد ورضى اللهم
عن الاربعه الخلفاء الراشدين المهديين وعن
بقيه الصحابه وعن التابعين ومن تبعهم
باحسان الى يوم الدين وعنا معهم بعفوك
وكرمك يا واحسانك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واذل الشرك والمشركين ودمر اعدائك اعداء
الدين اللهم ثبتنا على قول الثابت في
الحياه الدنيا والاخره ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا
بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك رحمه انك
انت الوهاب واصلح اللهم احوالنا في الامور
كلها واختم اللهم في الصالحات اعمالنا
وبسعاده اجالنا وتوفنا يا رب وانت راض عنا
اللهم اجعل جمعنا هذا مباركا مرحوما
وتفرقنا تفرقا معصوما ربنا لا تدع لنا
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا هما الا فرجته ولا
مريضا الا شفيته ولا ميتا الا رحمته واغفر
اللهم لنا ولوالدينا ولاخواننا ولجميع من
سبقنا بالايمان واتنا من لدنك رحمه وهيئ
لنا من امرنا رشدا اللهم اتنا في الدنيا
حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار ان
الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي
القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر كر
والبغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون فاذكروا الله
العظيم فاذكروا الله العظيم الجليل يذكركم
واشكروه على نعمه يزدكم ولذكر الله اكبر
والله يعلم ما
تصنعون الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
ان شاء الله شهاده باذن
الله استووا واستقيموا اعتدلوا
تراصوا سدوا الخلل ذوا بين المناكب
والاقدام الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصرا المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت
الناس يدخلون
في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفر
انه كان
توابا الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غغير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تبت
يدا ابي لهب و
وتب ما اغنى عنه ماله وما
كسب سيصلى نارا ذات لهب
وامراته
حماله
الحطب في جيدها حبل
منسد الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
‏s السلام علكم رحمه
الله السلام علكم رحمه الله
[Silence]
‏as 2500 squ more to what the existing s
was and at the c of
225000 that's
0 now the reason for this such a small
number is because we are using our
brothers and
help and family they have tremendously
helped us in making this thing done in
the best way
[Silence]
‏now
‏take
other name trans us
‏think are
name taes you need to those ta to the st
of that thaty so i just want you to know
right now have this year
90 for the and you know again half of
that is for the
indiv we received last year important
number to weed year so
13000 again ofy from
just ta to state of 133000 not nothing
to sne at and this year our go is to
reach that 000 so i
‏any pleas on the